Other examples having to do with the sequence and the way things play out:...
...a British company decided to sell off a division. They were going to sell it...
...and yet they hoped for a good chunk of cash that they could use to fund higher strategic priorities.
They looked around for natural buyers of this division and it was pretty clear...
...that an Australian company was the most promising candidate, the sort of natural buyer.
So this chief executive of the British firm,...
...who turned out to who have gone to school with the Australian chief executive, got on the phone and...
...said, "We've got this property. It looks like it'd be very helpful to you."
"We're going to be disposing of it and use the funds for higher strategic priorities."
"Are you interested?"
Well, the Australian CEO was interested but said,  "You know, we're terribly busy."
"And to get my people to do this transaction justice,..."
"...we really need a six or an eighth - month exclusive..."
"...and then we can devote the focus to that."
Well, imagine the poor number two to the British chief executive...
...flying off to Sydney with an urgent mandate there to get the maximum price for this new division...
...and suddenly realizing that he had no alternatives and was foreclosed...
...from talking to anybody else for eight months.
Essentially, his no deal option had been inadvertently destroyed.
And as a function of tactics or deal design,...
...he had just managed to mess up his own setup.